con 637 votos a favor la eurocámara vota
de una resolución un contundente mensaje
de apoyo a ucrania en esta resolución se
ha aportado que se considere a ucrania
país el candidato para la unión europea
siempre y cuando se cumplan las
condiciones ya sabiendas de que es un
proceso largo y complejo también se ha
apoyado con aumentar la ayuda
humanitaria a ucrania también que la
unión europea prepare planes de
contingencia ante las inevitables
consecuencias económicas que pueden
provocar las sanciones a rusia
precisamente también han pedido que
aumenten estas sanciones contra vladimir
putin la resolución se ha producido tras
un intenso y también emotivo debate en
que se ha escuchado al presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski que ha
participado en el inicio de la sesión
ante el pleno en que ha pedido a los
eurodiputados ya europa que no se olvide
a ucrania y que sigan apoyando al país
el ambiente en la eurocámara ha sido de
gran apoyo a los ucranianos hay bandas
por toda la institución de ucrania
también en pancartas y mensajes también
con camisetas que apoyan al pueblo
ucraniano todo esto junto con la
resolución son importantes mensajes
políticos que ha querido enviar hoy la
eurocámara de apoyo de europa hacia
ucrania